>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY."
THIS MORNING, PRESIDENT TRUMP
WENT AFTER THE MUELLER
WITCH HUNT, "TOTALLY
CONSTITUTIONAL
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, I WON'T PLAY
THE GAME BECAUSE I, UNLIKE THE
DEMOCRATS, DID NOTHING WRONG."
I CALLED HIM THE GREAT ONE.
HE'S THE HOST OF "CRT LIVE-IN
TV," NUMBER ONE SHOW ON FOX --
THE IDEA THAT A PRESIDENT CAN BE
INDICTED, I WANT YOU TO DEAL
WITH THAT.
I WANT YOU TO DEAL WITH THE IDEA
OF PART INS.
THIS IS YOUR WHEELHOUSE, MARK
THE IDEA THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS
DONE ANYTHING WRONG, I SEE YOU
GOT YOUR PAPERS AND YOU ARE
PREPARED, SIR.
GO.
>> NUMBER ONE, THIS INDICTED
ISSUE, THE PRESIDENT CANNOT BE
INDICTED ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
MR. MUELLER IS AN INFERIOR
EMPLOYEE IN TERMS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
HE WORKS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
AND HE MUST COMPLY WITH THE
POLICIES OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
EVEN PUTTING ASIDE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE, HE CANNOT
DEFY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND BRING IN AN INDICTMENT.
I BELIEVE THEY ALREADY
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE THEY
WATCH YOUR SHOW.
BECAUSE ADDITIONALLY, WE KNOW HE
CAN TO EITHER BECAUSE OF THE
ARGUMENTS LAID OUT BY REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION AND DEMOCRAT
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU CANNOT CRIPPLE THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES BUT HE'S
THE MOST POWERFUL MAN IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, EXPECT HIM
TO HAVE HIS DUE PROCESS
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS PROPERLY
DEFENDED AT THE SAME TIME.
NO PRESIDENT HAS BEEN INDICTED,
THERE IS A REASON FOR THAT.
NO PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
BROUGHT BEFORE A FEDERAL GRAND
JURY, THERE IS A REASON FOR
THAT.
PERHAPS MR. MUELLER IS THE ONE
WHO WAS THE TYRANT, NOT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE APPOINTMENT CLAUSE OF THE
UNITED STATES CONSTITUTION,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOT WRITE
THAT.
LAST TIME I CHECKED THEM OF THE
BY ALL THE STATES.
THE DEFECT HERE IS THAT EVERY
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S APPOINTMENT IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL, EVERY SPECIAL
COUNSELOR'S APPOINTMENT IS NOT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
APPOINTMENT IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL
BECAUSE THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL, MR. ROSENSTEIN
ATTORNEY GENERAL, MR. ROSENSTEI
MR. ROSENSTEIN, HASN'T EDUCATED
HIMSELF ABOUT THE APPOINTMENT,
NORMAN CLAUSE.
BUT DOES NOT HAVE
THE POWER OR THE PRESIDENT AND
THE SENATE.
THE PRESIDENT NOMINATES
PRINCIPAL OFFICERS TO COME TO
THE SENATE AND THE SENATE MUST
CONFIRM.
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL, --
UNITED STATES ATTORNEYS,
ASSISTANT SECRETARIES.
THE PROBLEM IS MR. ROSENSTEIN
CONFERRED SO MUCH POWER ONTO
THIS SPECIAL COUNSEL, NO
SPECIFIC CRIMINAL STATUTES, NO
SPECIFIC INDIVIDUALS, AND THE
OVERSIGHT IS SO TACIT AND SO
LIMITED.
AS HE PROMISED, HE WOULD KEEP
HIS HANDS OFF OF MR. MUELLER.
HE'S CREATED AN UNCONSTITUTIONAL
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
I BELIEVE THAT THE PRESIDENT
CHALLENGES THAT ONE DAY, HE WILL
BE SUCCESSFUL.
NOW THE PARDON POWER.
THIS MEMO THEY KEEP REFERRING TO
ON CAPITOL HILL, MR. SCHUMER, OF
ALL PEOPLE, IT'S TWO AND A HALF
PAGES LONG.
PAGE ONE?
PAGE TWO?
PAGE THREE.
SEE MY EXES?
THOSE OF THE RELEVANT PART OF
THE MEMO THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH GOING ON TODAY.
THIS ARTICLE QUESTION MIKE
THAT'S IT.
UNDER THE APPOINTMENT OF THAT
NOBODY MAY BE A JUDGE IN THEIR
OWN CASE, IT WOULD SEEM THAT THE
QUESTION WOULD BE ANSWERED IN
THE NEGATIVE.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT CAN
DO, PARDON HIMSELF.
THIS IS NOT A LEGAL DOCUMENT.
THIS IS A JOKE.
HERE?
THERE AREN'T ANY.
DO YOU SEE ALL THE CASE LAW
HERE?
IT'S A NOVEL QUESTION BECAUSE NO
PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
INDICTED.
WHY ARE WE EVEN DISCUSSING THIS
PART?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," ONE OF THE
REPORTERS IN ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS SECTIONS IN THE PHONY
ARTICLE BASED ON THE LEAKED
LETTER PUTS IN THERE, IS THE
PRESIDENT SAYING HE CAN PARDON
HIMSELF?
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT CAN
PARDON HIMSELF!
HERE IS THE LANGUAGE IN THE
CONSTITUTION, ARTICLE TWO,
SECTION TWO.
THE PRESIDENT HAS THE POWER TO
TO -- EXCEPT IN CASES OF
IMPEACHMENT.
DO YOU HEAR ANYTHING THERE,
EXCEPT IN THE CASE OF THE
PRESIDENT?
ALL OF THESE PROTECTIONS ARE
BUILT INTO OUR CONSTITUTION TO
PROTECT OUR CONSTITUTION, TO
PROTECT THE PRESIDENT FROM THE
MOB, THE MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS
THAT ARE A MOB TODAY.
THEY ARE HERE TO PROTECT THEM.
IT'S NOT THE PRESIDENT VIOLATING
THE CONSTITUTION, IT'S THE MEDIA
WHO WANT THE CONSTITUTION
VIOLATED.
IT'S THE DEMOCRATS WHO WANT THE
CONSTITUTION VIOLATED.
IT'S MUELLER AND HIS MERRY BRAND
OF DEMOCRAT PROSECUTORS TIPPING
AROUND A CONSTITUTIONAL
CONFRONTATION.
AS I SAID HERE, EVERY TIME I'VE
BEEN IN YOUR SHOW, SEAN, THE
CONSTITUTION IS THE PRESIDENT'S
FRIEND.
I AM SPEAKING SLOWLY SO EVEN JOE
SCARBOROUGH CAN COMPREHEND WHAT
I'M SAYING.
EVEN CHRIS CUOMO CAN COPPERHEAD
WHAT I'M SAYING.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN THIS
DECISION BECAUSE OF WHAT IS THE
ROSENSTEIN DID, HE CREATED AN
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MONSTER WHO IS
THREATENING TO BRING THE
PRESIDENT IN FRONT OF A FEDERAL
GRAND JURY, WHICH IS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND HAS NEVER
BEEN DONE, WITH THIS NOTION OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE WHEN HE
EXERCISES THE PREROGATIVES, THEY
WANT TO INDICT HIM, WHICH HAS
NEVER BEEN DONE.
THE ONLY WAY TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS THE OLD-FASHIONED WAY,
THROUGH THE SENATE.
THAT IS IT.
IT'S NOT THE PRESIDENT WHO IS
THE THUG, IT'S MR. MUELLER WHO
IS THE THUG, IT'S NOT THE
PRESIDENT WHO IS THE
INCOMPETENT, IT'S MR. ROSENSTEIN
WHO IS THE INCOMPETENT.
THEY CAN MOCK THE PRESIDENT AND
HIS ATTORNEYS ALL THEY WANT.
THEY SHOW UP IN THE
SUPREME COURT, I'M BETTING THAT
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS ATTORNEYS
WIN.
>> Sean: YOU ARE SAYING THE
CONSTITUTION IS ON THE
PRESIDENT'S SIDE AND HE NEEDS TO
TAKE IT AND HIS ATTORNEYS NEED
TO TAKE IT ALL THE WAY.
LAST POINT.
>> I'M SAYING WHETHER IT'S THE
APPOINTMENTS CLAUSE OR THE
PARDON POWER OR THE ISSUE OF
INDICTING THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES, HE IS RIGHT ON
HONEST WEEDS AND HE'S MAKING THE
PEOPLE WHO IS CRITICIZING HIM
LOOK LIKE FOOLS.
WHERE THE     HELL THE IS UNITED
WHERE THE     HELL THE IS UNITES
WHERE THE     HELL THE IS UNITEA
WHERE THE     HELL THE IS UNITEE
WHERE THE     HELL THE IS UNITES
CONGRESS?
THEN TO ASK MR. ROSENSTEIN SINCE
HE RECOMMENDED THAT COMEY HAS
BEEN FIRED.
THEY NEED TO ASK ABOUT THOSE
MEMOS OUT OF THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE -- WHAT AUTHORITY DOES
HE HAVE TO EVEN CONTEMPLATE
INDICTING A PRESIDENT QUESTION
MIKE WHY HAS HE NOT VIOLATED THE
APPOINTMENTS CLAUSE OF THE
CONSTITUTION?
ARTICLE ONE!
RATED FIRST IN THE CONSTITUTION!
THEY DO NOT HAVE TO SIT BACK AND
WATCH ALL THIS!
THEY NEED TO GET INVOLVED!
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY I CALL YOU
THE GREAT ONE, MARK.
SO IMPORTANT WE GET THIS RIGHT.
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC
DEPENDS ON IT.
YOU CAN SEE HIM SUNDAY NIGHT.